je suis juste sur voce voilà hockey
chaque fois que je vois de l'eau je suis
ivre c'est une maladie c'est trop la
honte d'eux
c'est bien que vous soyez pas debout
vous êtes allongé vous avez un problème
de vision non je suis en hd 720p c'est
le soleil dans la gueule ça trop de
soleil à marseille
bonjour baba
la tour eiffel c'est par où je crois que
cette fin de la bonhomie à je voulais
être appelés donc non donkey kong
je connais pas ouais c'est un pote à moi
abbott
je viens de chanter une petite chanson à
la claire fontaine fait perdre en sépia
vous êtes marseillaise sont très
gentilles mrc l'entr'aide des
marseillais franchement
j'espère qu'on fera au moins 300 élus
avec cette merde si tu arrives et ça
fait quoi
il s'appelait faut pas manquer j'ai pas
agi je souffrais trop nombreux alors eh
bien je me suis fait plus mais hier et
depuis je suis tous azimuts et c'est pas
pareil a bloqué qu'est ce que vous
faites tous dans maubeuge ont vu n'est
pas la note c'est bien non vie comme un
super joli
et tu t'appelles pas sylvie joly
la semaine dernière j'ai vu un mec qui
s'est pris un poteau imaginaire encore
plus content moi ça va pas je me suis
pris le panneau en pleine gueule quand
même c'est une drôle d'idée de mettre
des panneaux partout
non mais a pas de bonne ou la cie là
juste là bien vous allez ou là là je
vais marcher un petit peu vous savez
vers la gare je pense que je l'avais à
la gare je vais y aller en mono
j'ai d'autres dirhams ou nous qui il
était bien le moonwalk ce que je le
travaille en ce moment face à face à m
vous savez le faire vous le moule par
contre vous savez le critiquer
ça pique
je suis allongé dans la mer je suis si
vous avez un coeur abonnez-vous et si
vous n'en avez pas et vous allez très
vite mourir des raisons et pour voir une
vidéo badass cliquez ici retrouvez le
fat joe tous les mardis 20h50 sur ngtv